there is michael madsen hello and in man
you certainly can
welcome to the show yeah good for you
you ready to roll yeah yeah take your
jacket off make yourself at home man you
can do whatever you like sir yeah what
to him you can do whatever yes exactly
honey I might have some objections
michael madsen getting settled in he of
course he is
of course he is explosion Jones so
Michael you forgot your uh okay you
forgot your ID this morning yeah they
told us could we do they say you're
running late but they said you had to
wait for your because the security here
is a nightmare no is it my fault is it D
panicking I think I had a fissure had
they finally get you up Jimmy you know
how they get you up here without the ID
that's what I said you would think so
people would just recognize you you've
been in you know a hundred films throw a
DVD at them for God's sake and let him
know who's coming on it comes in it does
I was gonna ask you if you had that were
you getting like will you forget ID
somewhere or something else happens and
like you just got to kind of rely on
like look just go go me and you'll see
why rely on it but but sometimes it
happens and I don't expect it but it's
nice you know yeah when did you get into
New York yesterday oh okay so even
having a good time since you've been
here mmm was sleeping catching up on
rest
listen yeah I was in Cairo and they went
from Cairo to Chicago to Toronto Wow
to Germany and it's been a bit of a
journey yeah it sounds like what you do
in Cairo you doing press for this or is
there no I wanted to take my wife to
Egypt you did yeah how was it goes I had
to do a show there
and you know you can't just say honey hi
I'm going to Egypt you just can't
it doesn't work it doesn't fly
no no so when you say you wanted to take
her to Egypt you had to take her to
Egypt well I had to and I wanted okay we
start going there though cuz certain
places scare me to go to because they've
had like terrorist activity no no no
there's none of that [ __ ] they say that
and they say that and they say that
because they want to scare the [ __ ] out
of people
it's like CNN they just want to destroy
everybody in there's just a bunch of
[ __ ] it said so okay so you don't get
concerned with that so you go over there
and you didn't you had Anna do you go
see like the pyramids and Wow look at
this handing Sam his phone is that you
and your wife on a camel yeah by the
pyramids yeah look at how cool that is
yeah that's kind of what you do you take
the camel ride there that looks fun you
can see the three pyramids in the back
he offered me one thousand camels for my
wife she's very beautiful
one hundred coming Wow maybe a hundred
thousand oh yeah I take your wife over
the camel any day of the week they say
yeah I can't see it from there but okay
so when you were there how did you like
the pyramids had you seen them before
it's your first time um well I seen him
you know in National Geographic and on
TV but I never been there yeah so seeing
them and being there is a different
thing right
I had a feel but they take people inside
and it's really constant for what it is
right yeah that's hot and the Sun woody
when you walk inside how far in do you
go do you like I'll just a little area
or do you go for night and I
a hundred yards and I turn around I left
are you claustrophobic no I just I just
didn't like to be in there I would
probably like to do it but it might
freak me out a little bit into the
pyramids yeah but I might get the same
way a hundred yards in maybe I always
say I'm done I don't think in there man
there's nothing in there it's just like
a room it's like a lot of stairways and
little ladders and things and you might
think that there might be something more
interesting but there wasn't it'd be
cool to see just to see like what they
built on the inside right that they
built the staircases and ladders and
stuff like that but once you see it for
a minute ya seen it did you have any of
the awestruck by any of it like do you
have a moment where you're like wow this
is ancient people did it or did you not
hit you know I was I was born awestruck
by Easter Island I went to Easter Island
and I have to say that yes sir help
yourself
oh yeah
I thought Easter Island was a lot more
interesting because they cut those
little figures out of the side of a
mountain and they're like 40 tons and I
know Kevin Costner and decided he knew
how that was done
where did Kevin Costner say is very I
Got News for Kevin
they weren't moved on logs uh [ __ ] Kevin
Costner what does he know yeah yeah I
made a boring movie with him yourself
was it I did why I had her you didn't
like Wyatt Earp I thought it was slow I
see you did that instead of Pulp Fiction
right yeah already they wanted you to
play and you already were hosting for I
don't know it wasn't it wasn't it didn't
want to but I was contracted to do right
wider
so yeah buddy chill bill ratted he'll
ride and I did the hateful eight
so before you break my [ __ ] balls
[ __ ] you
I would probably hate Wyatt Earp too if
I sure that instead of Paul yeah I
figure there's a contract thingy no
Gore's
uh you know it was what it was I did
Reservoir Dogs yeah it was just to me it
was another gangster picture and I was
already contracted to do whiter so
Kevin's theory now about these things
being moved on logs you think is a
business ship it's a bunch of bunk yeah
you don't believe well they tried it
they laid them on the logs and then they
pushed them and the logs just went into
are they something yeah and there's no
trees of the eyelid so where you can get
the launch from doesn't make sense so
how do you think they did it what's the
prevailing theory I don't know but Kevin
Costner doesn't have it that's not your
he's [ __ ] he's an idiot he's a dope
III think that they had some
extraterrestrial help
yeah you do okay you think that that's
how the pyramids were built to a lot of
people think the pyramids
yeah Easter Island Stonehenge this is
alien stuff I think that was true I
believe that a lot I I do believe that
even as a kid I knew that was the truth
you you think that so do you think they
said that there were these maps that
look like they were the only way for
them to get the angle was to be well you
know above the earth and so you think
that they might have inspired the way of
the P like like the Nazca Plains all
right first of all you you wouldn't know
what they were
unless you were up in the air so Wow
why are they there it looks to me like
an airport so huh I guess whoever left
that maybe they'll come back someday but
uh do you think that the aliens are here
a lot of people think that aliens like
so so here's a prevailing theory the
aliens were here and they start
crossbreeding with humans and so now
like there's all these people that have
a
blood in them and don't even know maybe
maybe so maybe so wouldn't shock you
have you ever seen me I've never seen
any evidence of it but a lot a lot of
people have seen things have you ever
seen a craft or anything like that or
have you never had them yeah um I lived
in Chatsworth for a while my my my first
wife was George Ann and she was cher
sister and we lived at Val Kilmer's
father's property and trigger Street and
I seen a thing up in this guy one day
when we were there you saw that what do
you what did you see it was just like a
thing it was like I just sat there like
a saucer looking thing so he's a
structure it wasn't just like light no
no it was there and I've seen it and
then it went behind the club so and did
you tell people about it were you like
now they'll think I'm crazy yeah I
didn't tell anybody because everyone
yeah but Kevin Costner is the most like
sane person in the world with his log
theories right it's over right and again
do you think it's one of those things
where they with a target specific people
because some people have had multiple
encounters that was the only one now do
you think it's it we've talked about on
this show before and it's a fascinating
discussion do you think that it's
something that's being covered up
purposely by the government or I think
there's probably a lot of things that
they could tell the people but I think
that people might freak out I think they
might get scared and they might go
berserk and they might have a riot
and so you know there's some things and
just need not to be talked about
so keep everybody calm keep everybody in
order well there's so much [ __ ]
going on nowadays with people saying
this and saying that maybe it's time for
them to come back it'd save us right
yeah what do you think we're in bad
shape
strange you know do you think we're kind
of it we're in bad shape or well I think
everybody's too politically correcting
and everybody's hiding right Oh hiding
behind what they really believe you know
what's funny to me is there's
newscasters who basically what they do
is they read a teleprompter okay and
some of them are pretty cute and some of
them are handsome you know the handsome
guy is pretty girls and they're reading
your [ __ ] prompter and all of a
sudden they become celebrities all of a
sudden their opinion means like like
something important and they have little
facial gestures and a little you know
you know the eyes they roll back the
eyes
you know they they project the opinion
of the network that they work for and
that's not fair and that's not right and
that's not okay because the news should
be reported as the news you see now what
an opinion see based on the network's
opinion which they hammer them to do see
what do you think about the fact that
people though now have almost
acknowledged that and just look for
whatever news source agrees with their
opinion they find they find whatever
outlet agrees with them and that's what
they're gonna watch or read well I think
a lot of people are a lot less people
are watching those
kind of things now because they're not
stupid people are not stupid and they're
starting to see and they're starting to
realize that it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] and they're being manipulated
and so you know God bless you said
people are hiding which might be correct
to what what do you think they're hiding
from is they're afraid of being explored
you think it is where is all the people
who voted for Trump all right the guys
unanimously elected and they're
crucifying him on CNN
where's all the people that voted for
the guy where are they where the hell
are they they're in those airplane
hangars where he has his rallies well
they don't bother showing them so no
they don't show now do you think that
it's because they're afraid of being
identified with him and afraid of I'm
afraid to admit that they voted for him
I think there's an element of a view now
do you like him or do you not like him
that's a mixed question man you know
he's he's um he's trying to repair and
trying to bring back what was once
thought of by America but when he got
football players who are on their knees
during the national anthem what in the
name of God is that supposed to mean
these guys are athletes not professional
they're good at what they do do they
need to use our flag and the American
how is that okay I don't get it
see all say see you think that their
protest is ill place and they probably
shouldn't be doing it that way
I think there might be a better way to
do it yeah considering the fact that
they're NFL players and they've they've
arrived at a place of dignity and a
their play and their football players
and they're good at it
do they need to use that to crucify the
national anthem of our country but
hasn't that hasn't the NFL lost a lot of
their dignity based on their hiding
concussions and allowing wife be white
feeders to play I'm not gonna go into
that my daughter's and everybody does
that okay Michael Vick and you know
people they don't they make a big thing
out of she beat the dogs and the the dog
is attacking each other and the guy in
the elevator he smacked his girlfriend
have you ever smacked your girlfriend no
you're a liar [ __ ] liar no I haven't
I haven't fought a dog or or or a lady
I don't believe no and you've had sex
with both so you don't believe him you
think that that's just something that
guys do and that that the NFL is just
kind of like all right it is what it is
I think that sports should be sports and
I think that we should leave that alone
and I don't think it has any place in
politics are you a fan of sports a big
timer it is to something you like did it
ruin the NFL for you or do you not
really watch much I don't know no it
didn't ruin anything for me I I am I
think the Patriots are great ballclub I
think oh I used to like the Green Bay
Packers I thought they were great
right out of it I like the Green Bay
Packers um you know there's been some
great football players out there and
some it's a national American thing so
there shouldn't be any politics involved
in it winter shouldn't be an odd
question which is a little off the
subject I wanted to ask you about
internal affairs oh I [ __ ] I didn't
realize you were in that film what did
you do in that movie cuz one of the
first things on your resume
Jim is obsessed with this movie Internal
Affairs Richard Gere and he's like
threatening to have anal sex for this it
wasn't partners why was that it turn you
are not into it's on your resume no
somebody must have put that on still
getting those residual checks it said
you played Sean a stretch actually not
I'm getting I'm not getting any
residuals from internal affairs or
whatever you just said make it [ __ ] on
you you're making [ __ ] up well I would
never lie about your resumes Michael
Madsen Jim you have to know you're
talking IMDB is full of [ __ ] maybe
that's what it is yeah somebody put it
in they said you played oh they said you
know I made a mistake I was looking a
license oh my is that true thank you
thank you thank you for correcting that
I don't know I don't know how I thank
you for correcting it's embarrassed a
little mistake we all make him an art
school the guy paid for [ __ ] sake you
think then look at what happened because
they wouldn't do that that is true I
mean he wasn't not a nice they might
have been in it piece of [ __ ] he's it
was an average painter at best you think
if Charles Manson had been a successful
rock star he wouldn't have had Sharon
Tate and all them killed mmm maybe right
think about them that makes me you know
what that makes me scared of what the
hell Michael Madsen what if it wasn't I
think I think that he was a psychopathic
person when he infiltrated people to do
something bad for him because he was a
miserable [ __ ] and and he got
people to do stuff that he wanted them
to do and he did terrible terrible ugly
horrible things that's right
yeah and it's weird how how he sees like
seeing this kind of antihero people love
this guy and they take Manson yeah and
people are the banana
yeah they gotta andis brothers man they
shot their parents they blasted them
with shotguns and they lied about it and
then they went but Porsches and tennis
lessons and you know all of a sudden I
was sexually abused I think think you
sexually abused it not a reason to shot
than your parents okay why didn't they
just go tell somebody why didn't they
just do something about it or leave or
pack up and move out yeah I don't know
that I believe that excuse
um I don't either I don't know the
menendez excuse yeah I don't know if I
do either yeah what are you their comic
book man there's two of them
oh you want to Michael Manson you want
you want to meet the comic book men
we'll bring them in they're doing it you
haven't the comic book man you have a
you have a you have a guys you gotta
forgive me I'm a bit morning I was just
trying to tell me we're down a
microphone with that we're down a
microphone there's two of the guys are
here people over there they give me a
little what Mike is that Sam that's the
cowhide I know what maybe okay hold on
we're trying to figure this out we saw
him on the elevator
yeah hi guys sorry had you waiting with
his we're all backed up and we have
worked out a microphone Sam's microphone
broke yeah so we're now tall he's
talking I want note that Troy is no good
oh okay great great great
so what Mike would that be turning on
eight okay eight and you are right there
it is
the comic book men and michael madsen
michael man so we apologize for the wait
guys I'm sorry wait yes welcome it do
you do anything the comic book men are
in town because they're doing Comic Con
you ever do any of those Comic Cons
you're probably very very popular at
them um yeah they're a little bit weird
to do because you kind of feel like a
dishrag and you kind of feel like you're
taking advantage of people but really
but at the same time there's a lot of
wonderful wonderful fans and they are
very you know they're there
they're happy to see you they're sincere
and it makes their day and if I can do
that for for some money then so be it
do you guys get sick of doing them
because you do a lot of these things you
ever feel like a couple excuse me I
don't do a lot
oh no no I didn't mean you I make the
comic book men we're not you we're at
opposite ends of the spectrum I'm gonna
attach in horror so I love it I love it
I'm well I'm a short asian kid from
Michigan man like no one ever paid
attention to me before all this so so I
I love it so you like it then I I do
like it and you know you make nice
people they come there you you you make
their day yeah it's they make me very
proud and very happy to see you and
they're happy to handle it's money for
that too so that you know mine that
either be I I mean you know like I got
needs too I have I have six children so
you know I get it yeah
kids gotta eat yeah Mike that's my gate
it's not actually seven children seven
children she turned them all on um I
just found out that I have a daughter so
when did you find that out about a month
ago really my daughter how old is your
daughter she's 38
Wow how did you find that out my son
found her on Instagram do you know that
she's legit did you think yes yes I
think yes she is because I got my mom to
go visit her in Chicago and they did the
DNA swab on her mouth and I did the same
thing and I'm her dad so who was her mom
or who is Erma she was a cashier at a
car wash um and she's no longer living
that's doing was it somebody that you
knew well or was it somebody that you do
very brief I knew her well enough that
that happened yeah but wasn't
relationship right not a long-term thing
are you mad that she never told you um
I know things she had a chance to how
did she die young
she told my daughter and she thought I
was her dad but she left me alone Oh
so yeah she had her own problems so
we're not going to that okay so now that
she's 38 years old and you've spoken to
her have you met her I spoken to her and
I'm gonna go see her probably next month
oh cool Wow and how does it feel to know
that she's there and that you're gonna
get to see her
well considering the fact could have six
boys how about a little gal kind of nice
kind of a sweet thing that Lolo she's 38
kind of give her a big hugs and uh yeah
it's a nice thing that's a good thing
it's a wonderful thing you know your
mind a little bit though when you find
that out you like it sorry blow my mind
yes I always wonder like what do you do
if someday someone shows up and says hey
you got a I have none but to have six
and then having your first daughter you
know that's a huge happen to you Brian
yeah it happened to me earlier today
claimed it was my child it's happened to
me before I had I've had people in the
past if I know my brother or my my you
know and it all just turned out to be a
bunch of [ __ ] they were just trying
to get my money oh yeah
were you a very promiscuous young man
like is that an easy thing to take claim
do you have a sordid past
I wasn't promiscuous but I'll tell you
one thing it's a long swim to [ __ ] island
so long swim to [ __ ] island tell me my
arms are tired I have nothing against
nothing against people of that ilk and
god bless them yes but I am a
heterosexual male yeah you've got a lot
of evidence are apparently yeah I guess
six kids by seven children I mean that's
pretty that's pretty impressive do you
guys have kids or no I have two how old
twelve and ten okay and yourself I have
one she's 11 okay so now they into comic
books as well and by the way Michael is
promoting we should at least mention
what my he's promoting an animated
series and it is called explosion John
Jones and it's on go I'll go 90 you know
I met with them recently that's actually
like a really
big platform now it's geo 90 the number
90 calm and you can see explosion Jones
I'm guessing it's coming on now yeah
it's the El Rey Network its Robert
Rodriguez I did Sin City was wrong yeah
and he come up with this thing and
cartoon but it's very very well done and
I do the voice of explosion Johnson a
little daughter and wife that's passed
away and being chased by people who want
to do me in and it's very fun very fun
it's it's nice there's a lot of good
people on it to indicate Fox on a train
I think I would have made a good Batman
really you were mated yeah I think I
want to mean a great bed there's still
time right sure did you audition for did
you put your hat in the ring no no I
never did that they either know me or
they don't so you don't audition at all
I stopped doing that about 15 years ago
just because it's like you've proven
what you're there to prove well it's not
that it's just it's just it's just
demeaning it's yeah it's buffoonery it's
yeah you know it's like well I want her
to have Michael Madsen coming there and
he's gonna read for the this role of dog
you know then we're gonna give him be
[ __ ] money because he came in here so he
must really want it so that we won't
give him a [ __ ] time so it's one of
those you know it's a you kind of have
to be a man you kind of have to stand up
and say look guys you know you know that
I know that I can do it so why don't you
just hire me what do I look like I live
on [ __ ] island
[Laughter]
no no sir you doing which Batman movie
would you have most like to have done
there's the Michael Keaton there's the
Val Kilmer the George Clooney I mean you
go back as far as Adam West but you
probably don't forget about cloning that
was a joke
it was you didn't like him as Batman
right mmm [ __ ] him and the Kevin Costner
he wrote in on it anybody know did
anyone know nipples suited Batman by you
got the voice down you got the
definitely got this is this better than
Christian Bale's I totally agree
here we got the voice tone I mean I
could've don't want one of the earlier
ones I I liked Michael Keaton and I
thought that I thought that Jack was a
good Joker and great back with that
started I could have been a good Batman
but it's all been just emanated and just
ruined now it's like a joke now also but
once upon a time I think he could've did
it good yeah you know it's so weird cuz
like you do you would do a good Batman
but you know Jim my co-host like he's
actually become a little bit famous for
his Joker impression ya know it's
embarrassing but yeah I do have a pretty
good one well what like what would it
cuz you like
Nicholson but like what would your Joker
sounds I'm the Joker now Backman was a
Cesar Romero Lisbeth thank you that was
super cool thank you Sam doesn't agree
he doesn't think it's good I don't think
it's great [ __ ] it I agree [ __ ] his
right do you remember like like like
Frank Gorshin shunt when he was the
Riddler the Riddler in you remember a
Cesar Romero was a joker and Lee
Meriwether was the the Catwoman and and
Wow you know I got home I got a question
for the comic book man why did did Cesar
Romero Joker paint his paint over his
mustache you know just gonna say that
really I think he was probably really
mad that he didn't want to shave it off
and so he's just done come on don't
paint it over just paint over them it'll
look crazy he'll I'll be the Joker and
what we do
no I actually know why why do you why do
you paint over his mustache because his
wife couldn't come without you guys I
don't know do you think Michael been a
good Batman I mean let's be you guys are
experts on this yeah what do you think
is wrong with the way they interpret
characters in films from comic books oh
just say it's not bad they're just not
badass enough you know right they need
to be more badass well I think Christian
Bale though he went to like the darker I
thought was a bit too George Clooney he
did not do a good job too much neon I
would have loved to see a fat man that
cut people's ears off that would have
been awesome yeah
with with a straight razor just think it
says that's a persona I mean right so
Adam West started the whole thing that
was a little bit campy but there wasn't
so much the movie was bad it was the
Georges plenty of outcome in themselves
oh yeah it's like it's like it's like
Timothy Dalton playing James Bond right
you know what a joke Joe given those
chinos with the pleated G no no no no it
doesn't work no it doesn't work but the
thing was you know Christian Bale's a
little for my taste a bit a little stiff
and he said that it was weird using I'm
watching Heath Ledger when they were
doing the Dark Knight and he goes I'm
watching Heath Ledger do this amazing
thing and he felt kind of trapped in the
character choice he had made he didn't
feel as good about it
I think I think Heath was wonderful I
think it was a great Joker and he really
wasn't god bless him he's gone now I'm
but you know have you started
have you started working on this Roger
Avery film yet that you're doing with
Crispin Glover yeah I'm doing that um
was called lucky day why should he in
Toronto I did about five days already I
have to go back to Toronto to finish the
picture and you know Roger you know he
co-wrote pulp fiction yeah and he was
great pals with Quentin they both
actually worked in a video store
together which is bizarre and ironic if
you think about it but they're very much
alike and they're very much connected
with dialogue and storylines and um
Roger had a bad time for a while Quentin
you know rose to to what he is and he's
a great friend and a good director and I
couldn't say enough good things about
Quentin Tarantino how was how was
Crispin Glover cuz he's you're easier
he's your co-star on and how was it
working with memory
he is yeah he's an odd guy right we've
talked to him but you know in his
freakness um he has a certain dignity in
he is a gentleman and he's been a
gentleman to me and I think that he has
a great acting ability um he's kind of
like the Dustin Hoffman kind of you know
strange like like a Michael [ __ ] you
know like a
oh he's weird yeah but you know what
though in his weirdness he's a great
actor and he's always been a gentleman
to me and I will say that now Crispin
you're a gentleman a good actor what do
you think is Quentin's greatest strength
with with could you talk about being
dialogue driven and that to me is some
of the greatest stuff is that back and
forth normal type of calm
stations they have what do you thinks
his greatest strength with that you know
he has the ability to tell a story
without it being predictable and and and
it's not you can't put it down because
there's no remorse there's no it's hard
to explain another director Sam
Peckinpah George Stevens Billy Wilder
they had the ability to tell a story and
it was okay if it wasn't good because it
meant something and I think that Quentin
is very misunderstood sometimes because
he loves movies
he loves actors he loves stories and
it's not about the violence and it's not
about them that's not what it's about
for him he's telling your story that's
based in reality and everybody wants to
cut him down here and there but guess
what his pictures are very successful
and that speaks for itself yeah and
they're great they're successful but
they're great yeah it's criticizing
everyone and they're all good movies it
also speaks to the audience the guys
getting criticized for stuff that people
obviously want to see yeah so how would
he criticizing him for no there it is
you know he um he understands me he's
hired me to do a lot of his projects and
I know what he wants me to do and I
understand what he sees in me and III
bring it but I also know that I'm not
I'm not being dignify Matt I'm not I'm
not undignified I'm not a racist I'm not
a I'm not a mean person it's it's it's
just entertainment and it's done in such
a way nobody else can
do it like that I agree and just to
promote everything probably they're
telling us who don't have any clothes to
rap yeah weird everybody has to rap I
guess so you guys can't stay
they got go to Comic Con this may not be
the popular choice but if I'm casting
Batman
I cast chip chip or some chip chip
person probably would have been a good
Batman all [ __ ] whatever no chip chip
person is no he's [ __ ] he's a great
actor he's of comedic force he's just a
crazy he's one of these one of these
podcasters let's have Chris Rock play
Batman yeah bye Chris pebbles no you
don't say anything about Dave yeah very
funny better than George Clooney right
all right well they I they have to do it
George is a phony
he thinks he's he thinks he's Cary Grant
and he's not how do you know him
I met him yeah and he said he comes off
tries to come off like he's this
debonair guy yeah you know in those
twins you know it's like the Michael
Jackson thing those ain't made by him
okay is that right
you don't think they're his they were
produced you know in a lab yeah
laboratory okay so you think he's a
phony guy just but as an actor or as a
guy too because of what your experience
godblessu me man
kela everyone loves it you know that's
true you don't give a [ __ ] about it
so did Sammy Hagar though that's true
though you know I know anybody he thinks
is a [ __ ] Romeo and he's not right
he's a little because of little babies
and not a Romeo at all not at all I mean
I mean I don't like madmen you know he
needs an upper body workout right he's
not in the shape that he thinks he's in
he's weak chested I feel like this is a
precursor to celebrity boxing mr. badson
over there oh thank you yes absolutely
thank I got a hundred bucks on you thank
you buddy
thank you thank you much take the [ __ ]
out of him